[MUSIC PLAYING]
BOB CORNWALL: I
want to start off
by welcoming everyone to
the next Talks at Google,
and next Talks at Google in the
Detroit office specifically.
And today we're really
excited, because we
have the creative team behind
the new opera "Hadrian," which
is debuting this Saturday.
It was commissioned by the
Canadian Opera Committee,
and it will be across
the street at the Four
Seasons of the Performing
Arts Opera House,
which is very exciting.
So with me here today on
the panel I've got Rufus.
I've got Daniel, Peter,
Cori, and Isaiah.
So could you guys please give
them a round of applause?
[APPLAUSE]
And I really just want
to start off really
quickly by saying thank you
to you guys for coming today.
It's the day before
you open, so I
imagine your schedules
are kind of crazy.
You've got a lot going on.
So know that we
appreciate your time,
and we wanted to thank you
for all being here today.
We hope to spend this time
getting through each one of you
a little bit better.
We really want to
learn about the opera.
This audience is
curious about the opera.
We're not aficionados
by any means,
and so we want to learn a little
bit about the opera in general.
And then we want to talk
a lot about "Hadrian."
So that's what we want to
accomplish over the next 45
minutes to an hour or so.
So to kick things
off, what I love
to do is just go down the line,
and if you could really quickly
say your name, what you
do, and because we're
at Google, the last
thing that you Googled.
[LAUGHTER]
CORI ELLISON: Oh my god.
BOB CORNWALL: It's
really revealing.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Who wants to go first?
Isaiah, I'm looking at you.
ISAIAH BELL: My
name's Isaiah Bell.
I am a tenor.
I play the role of
Antinous in "Hadrian."
And the last thing I
googled was Grey Gardens,
but the restaurant.
[LAUGHTER]
BOB CORNWALL: Well done.
Cori?
CORI ELLISON: Oh,
I'm Cori Ellison.
I'm the dramaturg on this show.
And nobody knows
what that is, but I
suppose we'll talk a little
bit about that later.
And the last thing
I actually Googled
was Google to find
out how to get here.
[LAUGHTER]
BOB CORNWALL: Did we show up?
We did, good.
CORI ELLISON:
(LAUGHING) Yes, yes.
BOB CORNWALL: Whew!
That would have been awkward.
PETER HINTON: Hi,
I'm Peter Hinton,
and I am the stage
director for "Hadrian."
And the last thing I Googled--
I got to say I
think was weather.
BOB CORNWALL: Oh, yeah.
PETER HINTON: Just because it's
been so hot and then so cold.
BOB CORNWALL: Lot
of utility there.
Love it, thank you.
DANIEL MACIVOR: My
name is Daniel MacIvor.
I'm the librettist.
I had to look-- what do I do?
[LAUGHTER]
The libre-- sometimes,
I'm so new at this,
I want to say librettisist.
So anyway, I'm the librettist.
That means I wrote the words.
And the last thing I Googled was
does popcorn cause indigestion?
[LAUGHTER]
BOB CORNWALL: Have
you recently--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CORI ELLISON: Does it?
DANIEL MACIVOR: It can-- acid.
It can be--
[LAUGHTER]
BOB CORNWALL: Not
only entertaining,
but this is being educational.
I love it, this is great.
And Rufus.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Hi,
I'm Rufus Wainwright,
and I am the composer
of the opera.
I'm also a performer,
and singer, and ex-model.
[LAUGHTER]
BOB CORNWALL: That's obvious.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT:
When you boil it down,
and what was the
last thing I Googled?
I hate to say it, but I've
been Googling the stock market,
just because it's looking like
it's going to get fun again.
[LAUGHTER]
Because of the midterms,
it's a long story.
Anyways, OK.
BOB CORNWALL: Is there
anything specifically you're
watching on the stock market?
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: I'm
just waiting for it
all to crash so that
the Democrats win back
the House and the Senate.
BOB CORNWALL: OK, OK,
got it, got it, got it.
Get it, we get it.
So part of today
too, I want to get
to know you guys a little
bit more personally.
So Rufus, you've had
an incredible career.
I've read everything
on your Wikipedia.
I haven't remembered it all,
but you've accomplished a lot.
You're a singer/songwriter,
albums released,
millions of views on YouTube,
which is very, very cool.
So I mean, other than me, who
is the most thrilling person
you've shared the stage with?
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Who was
the most thrilling person?
For those of us who are here
and tuning in at a certain point
and have a love of opera,
I had the opportunity once
of doing a concert with
Jessye Norman, the two of us.
And it was certainly thrilling.
Also somewhat
infuriating as well.
And there was an amazing
thing where we had done it
on a summer afternoon
and the weather
had been really up and down.
It had been raining all day,
and it was in the evening.
And suddenly it was
very hot and very balmy.
And it was in Long Island
in the countryside.
And she got out and
started singing,
and all of a sudden,
all of these bugs
appeared because of
the drastic weather.
You know when that
happens in the summer.
And these bugs appeared.
And she started singing, and the
bugs started to surround her.
BOB CORNWALL: Oh dear.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT:
And she completely
was oblivious to this.
I mean, she knew
it was happening,
but she just didn't react.
And she sang this note--
and I think she was doing the
song "Summertime," actually,
and she sang this
very high note.
And all of a
sudden, all the bugs
attacked the entire front
row of the audience.
[LAUGHTER]
And they had to go running
away from their seats.
And she didn't bat an eyelid.
She was like, this
happens sometimes.
BOB CORNWALL: That's
very exciting.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: So she could
control bugs with her voice.
That's pretty amazing.
BOB CORNWALL:
That's really cool.
[LAUGHTER]
That's awesome.
And Isaiah, so you
introduced yourself
as a tenor, which-- to people
in the audience and online,
if you guys don't know,
that's an opera singer.
And opera singers
notoriously are sometimes
known as a little diva-esque.
What do you think is your
biggest diva quality?
[LAUGHTER]
ISAIAH BELL: I think for the
most diva-esque thing about me
is that I have enough
self-possession to hide
all my typical diva qualities.
BOB CORNWALL: Oh, great answer!
I love that, I love that.
And Cori, you had sort of
mentioned you're a dramaturg?
CORI ELLISON: Mm-hm.
BOB CORNWALL: Can you
explain a little bit
about what is a dramaturg
and how do you become one?
CORI ELLISON: How
do I become one?
Well, with great difficulty.
I was just saying to my friends
here that there currently
exists no training program
in North America for opera
dramaturgs.
And I'm in the process of
creating one for American Lyric
Theater in New York.
But to answer your question, an
opera dramaturg, or a dramaturg
in general in the context
of developing a new work
is a person who works with
the composer and librettist.
And the first thing is
to really understand
what it is they're trying to
do, the piece that they're
trying to create, and
to help them do that.
And it sounds like a
no-brainer sort of no-show job
or something like that.
But often it's not,
because artists
have very distinct visions.
And a composer
and librettist may
come to the same project
with different visions
because of just who they are.
So the trick is-- without at
all imposing my own opinions
about it-- to try to bring them
together and show them where
they're really intersecting.
And maybe they don't
think they are.
But just really
help the project--
BOB CORNWALL: Come together.
CORI ELLISON: --gel by helping
the artists gel together.
And that boils down to big
aspects of the piece, details,
lots of different
things along the way.
And then of course, when Peter
Hinton joined in as director,
then my task with
the creative team
was sort of to introduce them
to this piece, which was not
something they could look up in
a book or Google at that point.
BOB CORNWALL: Yeah, that's true.
CORI ELLISON: And so I sort
of introduced it to them.
BOB CORNWALL: You were Google.
CORI ELLISON: I was.
[LAUGHTER]
I was Google.
BOB CORNWALL: That's right.
DANIEL MACIVOR: You
are kind of a Google,
because you know so
much about opera.
That's another thing, right?
You have a wealth of knowledge.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT:
Wide variety of--
BOB CORNWALL: Yeah,
I was going to say,
what got you to this point?
What have you done
in the past that
enables you to do this so well?
CORI ELLISON: Well,
I've grown up--
I mean, I've been an opera geek
since I was seven years old,
really and truly.
And so I've absorbed
a lot of opera.
And it's really
just been my life.
And so I know a lot about the
existing repertory of operas.
And that's really helped me work
with composers and librettists
of today.
Because the best
teachers, in a way,
are the great composers
and librettists like Mozart
and Da Ponte or Verdi and Boito.
And there's no challenge that
a composer and librettist
of today is going to encounter
that a great composer
and librettists of
the past didn't.
So often, when you're
trying to solve a problem,
you'll go to a model in
the standard repertory
and say, look at
what these folks did
with the same challenge.
BOB CORNWALL: Yeah,
that's awesome.
It sounds like an
incredibly challenging role
as you bringing
everyone together
and try to get everyone on the
same page with the same vision.
CORI ELLISON: It
can be challenging,
but it's also
incredibly rewarding.
It really, really is.
BOB CORNWALL: That's awesome.
CORI ELLISON: And this
week, after so many years--
over four years in my
case of being involved
in the development
of this piece--
it almost seems unreal
that tomorrow it's
actually going to happen.
BOB CORNWALL: Yeah, that's true.
And now Daniel, you had
the other interesting title
of librettist?
Am I saying that correctly?
DANIEL MACIVOR: Librettist?
BOB CORNWALL: Yeah,
and so can you explain
like what is a librettist?
DANIEL MACIVOR: A librettist
is the writer of the words.
So I write the words, whether
they're-- well, all the words.
There's very few words
spoken, a few words spoken.
There's probably about
maybe 30 words spoken.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Actually,
my daughter, who's seven,
went to the opera.
And we said, what's
your favorite part?
And she went, the
part where the woman
says, the underworld suits you.
[LAUGHTER]
DANIEL MACIVOR: That's so
funny, that's so funny.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: That's
one of the spoken parts.
BOB CORNWALL: I love that.
DANIEL MACIVOR: Good.
So there are spoken
words, and I wrote those.
And I also write the
words that are sung.
So basically, I write something,
and I give it to Rufus.
And then we sort of--
Rufus writes music, and
sometimes he writes music
to what I've written, and
and then we incorporate
what I've written,
or sometimes he
makes suggestions
about something else I might
write that would fit the music.
So I'm just the word guy.
BOB CORNWALL: Yeah, OK.
And it sounds like--
I was curious about
how the process works
between like writing the words
versus writing the music.
And it sounds like
sometimes the music leads,
sometimes the words
lead you guys.
It's really just
about coming together,
depending on what you've
got in front of you.
Is that fair to say?
DANIEL MACIVOR: Yeah.
BOB CORNWALL: Yeah?
DANIEL MACIVOR: That's fair.
That's fair.
BOB CORNWALL: The other thing
for the audience too, I'm
wondering, Rufus, if you can
explain what is "Hadrian?"
What is it all about?
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Oh boy!
BOB CORNWALL:
Yeah, big question.
DANIEL MACIVOR:
Could Google that.
[LAUGHTER]
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Well,
why don't we ask Peter?
BOB CORNWALL: Sure, Peter?
[LAUGHTER]
PETER HINTON: Well,
I'll give it a go.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: He actually
has the best perspective,
because he's--
PETER HINTON: "Hadrian" is an
opera about the second century
Roman emperor who
most of you probably
have heard about or
studied in school,
and is associated
with Hadrian's Wall.
But there are many things
that Hadrian was famous for.
And the opera looks at him
at the last day of his life.
And one of the things that
occurred during his reign
was he had a young male
lover named Antinous,
who, in October at this
very time of year in 130 AD,
he died.
And there was a lot of
mystery around his death,
whether it was a murder, an
accident, or a sacrifice.
And it radically shaped
Hadrian's latter part
of his reign.
And the opera is about that
relationship, about Hadrian
and Antinous, when they
met, their love affair,
and Hadrian's pursuit of that
mystery, what happened to him
and how he died.
So it's an opera that's
a lot about empire
and what empire
represents and means.
But it's also about
personal desire and love,
and it's cost and it's risk.
So it's historical, but also
incredibly contemporary.
And it's the thing
that really drew me
to it is that it's not
like BBC "Masterpiece
Theater" or something.
It's not like the
historical in that way.
It's very romantic and very
political at the same time.
So I think in our own age
of how we define ourselves,
and how we are socially
identifying ourselves,
it's very modern in that sense.
BOB CORNWALL: You hit
on a lot of themes
about why this story
is so relevant today.
And what I'm
curious about is how
long ago did you guys actually
start working on this opera?
And at that point, how
did you choose this story?
Why this story and why now?
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Well, I read
the book over 20 years ago.
BOB CORNWALL: Wow.
And--
CORI ELLISON: You
have to say what book.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT:
Oh, sorry, the book.
[LAUGHTER]
I read the book "The Memoirs
of Hadrian" by Yourcenar.
It wasn't over 20 years,
it was almost 20 years ago.
And I knew that it would
make a great opera, just
the whole context
with those characters
and in that time
period and so forth.
So I always held onto that
idea of writing that opera.
But I also had been
at McGill in music.
And at one point, I was
studying composition and piano.
And then at one point I
thought, well, maybe I'll
study opera singing.
And I went in, and
I was wearing clogs.
[LAUGHTER]
And the opera teacher said,
you have a great voice,
but you can't wear those clogs.
At which point I dropped
out of music school thanks
to that comment.
[LAUGHTER]
Either the clogs go or I do.
BOB CORNWALL: Good choice.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Yeah,
so I went with the clogs.
So needless to say I sort
of skipped out, literally,
of sort of the formal
musical education
in the classical sense.
And I knew I wanted to
write "Hadrian" as an opera,
but I didn't feel confident
enough in my abilities
in terms of orchestration, and
just doing that kind of stuff
that I could do it.
So I wrote "Prima Donna" first--
my first opera-- and
learned all that I could.
And then thankfully, Alexander
Neef, the head of the COC,
he came to those performances.
He heard that I wanted
to do "Hadrian,"
and he commissioned me to do it.
BOB CORNWALL: Wow, and
how long ago was that?
Like how many years ago.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: That was--
oh God, almost 10 years ago.
BOB CORNWALL: Wow!
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: 10 years ago.
BOB CORNWALL: So this has
been like a work in progress
for a decade?
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Yeah.
DANIEL MACIVOR: And then
about five years ago,
Alexander got in touch
with me and asked
if I would get involved.
And so Rufus and I
met, and we immediately
started talking about ideas.
And it seemed like there
was something there.
Then about three,
four years ago, Cori
became part of our little
thing, and the three of us
would work together.
And then about a year ago,
Peter became part of the team.
And then from Peter,
then we got cast.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Then we
gave birth to this child.
[LAUGHTER]
BOB CORNWALL: To this young man.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: --of
all of our genetic traits.
PETER HINTON: Isaiah.
[LAUGHTER]
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: With
his mother's hair.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT:
He's got my face.
[LAUGHTER]
DANIEL MACIVOR: He's
an ectomorph like me.
BOB CORNWALL: That's amazing.
PETER HINTON: Isaiah in
the opera plays Antinous.
And Antinous was like--
it's such a daunting
challenge for a performer.
Because he was known
throughout antiquity
as being the most beautiful
male, the epitome of--
[LAUGHTER]
And so it's like it's
such a huge thing.
and so I remember it
was last December,
and we were beginning design
meetings and stuff (LAUGHING)
in Toronto.
And Alexander came and said, oh,
we found a fantastic Antinous
for you.
His name is Isaiah Bell.
And we're Googling what
he looks like right away.
That's the first thing we did.
And Isaiah has an app
which adapts your face
to what you might
look like at age 60,
and that's what came up.
[LAUGHTER]
Wow, he's got a great voice.
Well, he's kind of wild-looking.
BOB CORNWALL: One more time.
DANIEL MACIVOR: Isaiah came
to see a performance of mine
in Victoria, because
he lives in Victoria.
And someone came and said, I
want you to meet your Antinous.
And I turned around,
and I saw him.
And it was kind of embarrassing,
because the first thing I said
was, you're handsome!
[LAUGHTER]
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Oh, good!
DANIEL MACIVOR: --excited.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CORI ELLISON: And it
took a while to find.
Antinous was actually the last
cast member that we found,
because it was kind
of like a bake-off.
All of us were
running around trying
to find handsome young tenors.
[LAUGHTER]
We were kind of emailing
Alexander-- oh, I
heard somebody, I saw somebody.
But Isaiah was the winner.
BOB CORNWALL: Wow,
that's amazing.
And so this will be the
world premiere this Saturday.
And so, Isaiah, I'm curious
from your perspective,
what is it like
prepping for a role
that actually, no one else
has really had before?
Like what have you done to
prep for this role of Antinous?
ISAIAH BELL: People have been
asking me this question a lot.
And I actually think that for
me personally as a performer,
the actual process of preparing
the role of a new opera
isn't or shouldn't be that
different from preparing
a role from another opera.
Because when I'm preparing
a role of something that's
been performed for
hundreds of years
or even written from
this last century,
I don't like to
spend a lot of time
at the beginning of the
process going through all
the famous performances of it.
We were talking about this
before we came on, actually,
the idea of as a performer,
whether you see yourself
from the outside
in, like what you're
doing as it appears
to other people,
or whether you try
to make it more
motivated from the inside out?
And so when I'm
preparing any role
I try to start with
what's there in the text,
and what's there in the music.
And what we discuss
based on that,
and what we build from
the inside of the project.
And then maybe if
I'm doing something
that has been done
many times before,
maybe at the very end, if I
have a problem with something,
or if I want to see just some
small detail how someone else
did it I might listen to them.
But I don't think that
you want to model yourself
on other performers.
So for me, all the
stuff around it
is very different in
terms of the hype,
and in terms of
you're not necessarily
going to do a Google talk
about "The Elixir of Love"
or one of these operas
has been done 300 times
unless you're doing it
in a really radical way.
But from the inside, it's
a very similar process.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: I actually
have an interesting question
about that, which I think
it's OK to talk about, though.
I mean, I think for
you, for a young singer,
it's probably a
wise role to take.
But I do feel like for someone
like Thomas Hampson, who
plays Hadrian--
and he's one of the great
opera stars of the world.
For him it's actually
really interesting for him
to do new roles, because he's
done all the other ones so
many times.
And he's sort of--
and the voice changes, shall
we say, as you get older.
And they'll always be
compared to past performances
of how many Alfredos
or how many Toscas--
but then to come and do a
new role is a great kind of--
I think for an older singer,
and a very established singer,
it's a really good
move in terms of just
keeping your career going.
Is that true?
CORI ELLISON: Yeah, I would
say definitely, absolutely.
But I think for singers
all across the board,
to have the feeling
that you participated
in the creation of this piece--
I mean, when this
piece gets done again--
and I have every confidence that
it will be done a lot again,
that people will come
to it-- and things
that have been set
kind of in stone
were partially the way they are
because of Isaiah, and Thomas,
and Karita and Ambur
Braid, and all the people
who are participating in the
world premiere production.
We did rewriting of music
and words to suit them,
and certain staging
choices as well.
So they've been very much a part
of the formation of this piece.
ISAIAH BELL: I would
say that once we
got into the rehearsal room,
the thing that was really great
is how much we did have
a dialogue about how
things worked practically.
And that's something
that's very exciting,
and that you don't do if you're
singing an opera that's been
established by someone else.
And I also like that no
one is coming to the show
and thinking, well, Jon Vickers
is my favorite performer
of this.
[LAUGHTER]
So it must be amazing
to work with him.
PETER HINTON: But I think
it's an interesting thing
with a new work
for the audience.
Because we come to
our favorite operas
with already our impression
of what we love about it.
So we come to
"Tosca" with an idea
of what we think "Tosca" should
be and how she should sound.
And what's great is to sit there
last night in the theater--
we had our sort of
open dress rehearsal--
and going, everyone is hearing
this for the first time.
And never mind, they don't
know how it's going to end.
They don't know what's
going to happen next.
And they don't know
about the music.
They're hearing this aria
for the very first time.
It's so thrilling.
CORI ELLISON: It's
an amazing feeling.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CORI ELLISON:
Because a way, opera
can be like the "Rocky
Horror Picture Show,"
that you come to it knowing
what's going to happen,
and you have your little
props with you and all that.
BOB CORNWALL: And you're ready.
CORI ELLISON: And
this is one reason
why even with
standard repertory,
I'm a firm believer
that synopses
shouldn't have spoilers.
Because maybe there is
somebody in the audience who
hasn't seen "Boheme" before.
Do they have to know that
Mimi dies at the end?
Sorry if you didn't know.
[LAUGHTER]
BOB CORNWALL: Just ruin it.
CORI ELLISON: But
you know what I mean?
And for them to know
enough about the piece
to know that they're
interested to come see it,
the story engages them, and
then come and have an experience
just like you would
if you were going
to a new film or a new play.
You don't come-- you know.
yeah.
BOB CORNWALL: Go ahead.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: But you
know what's interesting,
though, is that because I'm
mostly in the pop world,
and that's where I
spend most of my time
and where most of my fans
are, a lot of my fans
have never been to the opera.
BOB CORNWALL: That's true.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: And I
have had many experiences
where my opera was the
first opera they ever saw,
which is also exciting.
Because then, I think for
the opera world in general,
it's like, god, think of all
the incredible stuff (LAUGHING)
that you're about to
discover of the great works
that we kind of take for
granted that everybody knows.
There are actually huge pockets
of people, younger people,
mostly, who don't know that,
because it's not-- so it's
a nice sort of double sword.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CORI ELLISON: --creating
new opera fans for us.
BOB CORNWALL: Yeah, and this
is actually your second opera?
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT:
This is my second.
BOB CORNWALL: Yeah, so curious--
second time around-- what
are the lessons learned?
What are you doing the
same, what's different?
What is the process like?
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: We were
talking about this at lunch
today, Cori and
I. At the time, it
was pretty horrific what I had
to put up with my first opera.
Because it had been commissioned
by the Met, and then
we had a falling out.
And then I had to bring it
to England and so forth.
And what was going to take five
years had to take one year,
and it was all over the place.
And I could go on and on.
But I'm very happy with
"Prima Donna," my first opera.
It's a piece I love
very dearly, and I
think it'll actually survive.
But needless to say,
the whole experience
was pretty traumatic.
Whereas this one is light years
away from that in terms of what
I had to contend with.
But funnily enough,
I am so happy that
happened with "Prima
Donna," my first opera.
Because it really--
I don't know, I can
now appreciate fully
all the wonderful people
and talent, and really,
the opportunity that
I've had on this piece,
to have every facet
be of such excellence.
Whereas I think if I had not
had that struggle at the outset,
I wouldn't be aware
of how fortunate I am.
And so it's all the way
it's supposed to be.
BOB CORNWALL: Yeah,
they always say
it's those moments that are
harder where you do the most
learning, and where you
find gratitude too, right?
So I totally get that.
I also think--
Peter, you were talking
about how this story has
a ton of history.
And so as you're going
about building this opera,
I'm really curious about
what kind of research
you would have done.
How did you guys go
about mining the story,
and figure out how
you want to tell it
and what choices you
guys want to make?
PETER HINTON:
Well, there's lots.
I mean, there's lots of research
you can do on ancient Rome.
And I have my favorite go-tos,
like I really love Mary Beard.
If any of you have read Mary
Beard or seen her BBC program,
I adore her.
And she sort of makes
that classical world
very available, very relatable.
And so I really
love that in her.
But a thing that I really
said to the singers a lot
and to the designers
when we're working on it
is there are lots of
different Hadrians.
That's what you
find out when you
start researching, different
interpretations of Hadrian.
And our job was to
really to try to learn
Daniel and Rufus's Hadrian,
their telling of this story.
And they both have very
different inspirations,
very different reference
points, very different
historical influences,
and together
is the take on
Hadrian in this opera.
So that's the part I
really loved embracing,
was trying to understand how
these guys saw that story.
CORI ELLISON: If I could
elaborate a little bit on that.
The fact that any
time you create
a work of art that's
historically based,
whether it's a novel, or a
play, or an opera, a film,
you have a lot of
choices to make.
Because sometimes
there's a plethora
of material about the
character, and sometimes there's
very little.
And you have to either
fill in a lot of blanks
or make a lot of choices.
And also, the kinds
of choices you make
are for dramatic reasons.
You may sometimes
depart from actual fact
in order to get
at a deeper truth.
That happens very often.
There are other
historical operas
like "Don Carlos" by Verdi, or
"Boris Godunov" by Mussorgsky,
that don't tell the
letter of history,
but they really get at the
essence of a lot of who
these characters were.
DANIEL MACIVOR:
What did you say--
something this morning about
we have to imagine our past,
and imagine--
PETER HINTON: Oh yeah.
Like, I just think
we just get very
obsessed with historical
accuracy and fact-based things
as being based on a true story.
Where the way we imagine
our way into history to me
is far more interesting
than a history book
kind of telling of it.
Because why tell a story about
the second century AD today?
And how does it speak
to our own times?
It's a way to reflect
upon our own times
by considering it in
a Roman Empire way.
And that doesn't mean
you have to put senators
in business suits and give
people iPads in a production
to say it's relevant, you know?
BOB CORNWALL: That
makes me think about--
when you're in the process
of building this opera,
you must be thinking
about the audience,
and what impact you want this
opera to have on the audience.
So I'm sort of curious--
as the audience walks out
from opening night, what
is the impact you hope
this opera will have.
DANIEL MACIVOR:
We want to think,
I'm coming back
to see that again.
[LAUGHTER]
BOB CORNWALL: And again?
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: I'm thinking
of the next production that
takes place with
business suits and iPads
in the Google building.
[LAUGHTER]
Which will be
somewhere in Germany.
BOB CORNWALL: You've
come to the right place.
[LAUGHTER]
DANIEL MACIVOR: So it's a
very queer gang, isn't it?
We're a queer bunch, aren't we?
CORI ELLISON: Yes.
BOB CORNWALL: For sure.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Totally.
DANIEL MACIVOR: We're
quite queer here.
[LAUGHTER]
We're as queer as you
can get, pretty much.
[LAUGHTER]
Look at us all, queer as can be.
I mean, that's a big
part of it for me,
is that it's sort of
unapologetically that.
And sort of shocking,
as Peter has
said, that in 2018 it's still
shocking, but there it is.
There was a moment
at the beginning
of Act III, which is
after the intermission,
that Rufus had known about.
I think you told me about it the
first time we sat down to talk,
that there was this piece of
music you'd already written,
and you knew what was
happening with this music,
and it was the sex scene.
And I spent quite a bit of
time trying to dissuade you
from going for the
incredible detail
that you wanted
in that sex scene.
And when then people
started to come and react--
they were shocked by it--
I realized how important
it was that that be there.
Because I didn't realize that
you knew what would happen.
Anyway, so I think
that for me, the fact
that the queerness of
it is very important.
CORI ELLISON: And
that's really--
when we're talking about
why tell this story now--
Rufus, I think
for you that was--
am I right-- one of the main--
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Yeah, well,
one of the main things for me
was--
I've been an opera
fan since I was
a child, since I was about 13.
And I very much fell
into the whole tradition
of gay men going to the opera
to get a sense of solace,
to get a sense of belonging,
to deal with this feeling
of rejection and tragedy.
And especially for me, because
I was 13, and that was right--
it was 1987, so AIDS was
just decimating my community.
And I really did
think I was going
to die for a solid 10 years.
And I was probably not far off
the mark in thinking that way.
Anyway, so opera created
that safe place for me.
But the one thing
missing, of course,
was actual great
grand operas that
had fabulously larger than
life gay characters in them
on par with Tristan and
Isolde, or Don Carlos
and people like that.
So I don't know if
it was purposefully
done to try to introduce
those personalities,
but I do feel like it's a
strange kind of destiny.
It's meant to happen,
and I'm just you
know fulfilling that prophecy.
BOB CORNWALL: Yeah, it feels
very culturally relevant,
particularly in this moment.
And it's nice to see the opera
take on this type of story line
and tell it so unapologetically,
I think, is what I've seen--
DANIEL MACIVOR: Taken a while.
BOB CORNWALL: Yeah, but it's
really, really nice to see.
And I'm curious--
from any one of you--
what do you think it is
about the genre of opera that
can tell this story so uniquely
versus any other genre?
Why is this such a great opera?
CORI ELLISON: Please.
Well, I think it's a story
that just cries out to be sung.
It's so larger than life.
And even though it's
historic, it has so much
of the mythical about it.
And I think when you look
at the repertory of operas
historically, so many
of the great grand opera
certainly have exactly
this kind of story.
I've always said it reminds
me of the great Verdi operas,
in the sense that it's
a very personal story.
It's a love triangle.
It's a very deeply
personal story,
but at the same time,
set against the backdrop
of an entire empire
and its fate.
And this is very like what
you find in a Verdi opera,
and a lot of grand operas
like "Les Troyens" by Berlioz.
So I like to say it's a
21st century 19th century
grand opera.
DANIEL MACIVOR: It's
also about on some--
one of the first phrases that
I had received about this
was the phrase
inconsolable grief.
And I'm not going to see a
play about inconsolable grief,
sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
But if you can sing
inconsolable grief?
Yeah, I'll go.
I'll be there.
BOB CORNWALL: And
check that out.
No, I love that.
That makes a ton of sense.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: I
am curious, though,
how would you define it in terms
of your experience of seeing
other repertoire,
and where it fits in?
And if it is--
I'm not asking if it's a
great opera or not, but--
[LAUGHTER]
But in terms of--
BOB CORNWALL: We
know the answer.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: --in terms
of trying to be a great opera,
and going for what
great operas engender,
which is music that
lasts at least 100 years,
are you getting
that vibe at all?
[LAUGHTER]
As a singer?
I don't know.
ISAIAH BELL: Well, one of
the really wonderful things
about this opera
is its connection
to the history of opera,
which in itself is
something that has become
part of what makes opera.
Because opera is such
a historical tradition.
And since the creation of opera,
even at the very beginning
of opera--
the first opera that we
know about that survives
is "Eurydice," by Peri, and
also "L'Orfeo" by Monteverdi.
And these operas were
already calling back
to this grand tradition
of Greek theater
from thousands of years
before, hundreds and thousands.
And so I think opera as an
art form is tied inextricably
with the grander
elements of life,
of history, and of emotions
that are too big to just
be chatted about, you know?
And I think that that's
something that this opera
understands intrinsically--
and that you,
as a lifelong opera
lover, understand,
and it comes across
very clearly--
is that it's connected
to our human story.
And what I really love about
"Hadrian" and about many
of the great operas that I love,
like "Gloriana" by Britten,
which is actually very similar
in a lot of ways, which
juxtaposes this idea of empire,
and of your responsibilities
as a public figure, and your
responsibilities as a ruler
and someone who
has responsibility
for other people, with
your private needs
and your own desires.
And what's really
great about "Hadrian"
is that it understands
that interplay.
And it understands the
grandness of everything
that's out there,
like Toronto, Canada,
the world, Rome, everything.
And the grandness of these
things that are only just
seen behind a
flicker in the eye,
but it means everything
to you as a person.
BOB CORNWALL: Yeah, I
love that articulation.
That's so true.
When you have these
grand responsibilities
that are very public a
lot of the time, but then
you have these personal
grand responsibilities too.
The story does a
really great job
of demonstrating both of
those, and the tension in it.
ISAIAH BELL: The
interesting thing about this
is seeing in Hadrian's story
how all these things that
to almost everyone else in
the opera are everything.
They can't understand
why Hadrian is swept away
by this thing that seems,
in the scope of history,
so inconsequential.
And history hasn't had much
to say about Antinous in terms
of who he was as a person.
Hadrian made him
into something grand.
Hadrian made him into a god.
Hadrian made him into
someone to be worshiped.
But in terms of
what it was actually
like to be that person, or what
their relationship was like,
we don't know much about it.
DANIEL MACIVOR: Now we do.
ISAIAH BELL: But now we do.
BOB CORNWALL:
(LAUGHING) Now we do.
ISAIAH BELL: But I think
that it's interesting
that there's so much
grandness, and everyone
sees the story of
Rome, and how we
must preserve the story
of Rome in this opera.
And that's really what
most people's objective is.
And then there's this
very intimate thing
that, if you saw it
from the outside,
you wouldn't necessarily
understand what's important.
But to two people,
it's the only thing.
BOB CORNWALL: Yeah, totally.
Isaiah, I want to ask you too--
you talk about being
an artist in this role.
And very much, as an opera
singer, you're a huge artist.
I think you're also
an athlete as well.
And I'm super
curious, what is it
like to train for an opera
that's going to go live?
Like what does a day in the life
look like for you right now?
I have no idea.
DANIEL MACIVOR: The diary online
if you really want to know.
ISAIAH BELL: I do have
a diary that the COC has
asked me to write about
the process of this.
BOB CORNWALL: Fabulous.
ISAIAH BELL: But that training
that's spoken of in that
is mostly emotional.
First of all, I will
correct any misapprehensions
that I am an athlete.
I am not an athlete.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, we always say-- and my
first voice teacher corrected
the idea right off the bat--
that it is an athletic
art form in terms
of how you use your body.
You're engaging it with
it like an athlete,
and we do approach
it athletically.
But you're not
necessarily going to see
the results of that outwardly.
But the training for
something like this, for me--
I don't know if it is the same
for many all opera singers.
I know that just
talking informally
with many of my
colleagues, this is true.
But the training
is about, for me,
so much keeping an equilibrium
as you're going through,
especially a process like this,
which has so many needs, so
many personalities,
so many ups and downs
when no one knows what
it's going to look like.
And no one says--
if you're doing--
I don't know, I said
"The Elixir of Love,"
but if you're doing any opera--
or "Tristan and Isolde--"
not that I sing that-- but
any of these great things,
you may be struggling.
But you think well, this has
been done hundreds of times
before.
It's like the whole
idea of the first--
what is it-- the minute mile?
Do you know what
I'm talking about?
BOB CORNWALL: Four-minute mile.
ISAIAH BELL: Yeah,
four-minute mile.
As I said, not an athlete.
[LAUGHTER]
The first time someone
broke that, no one had ever
broken that record.
And then suddenly, it's
like bam, bam, bam, bam, bam
once we have it in our
head that it can be done.
BOB CORNWALL: Totally.
ISAIAH BELL: And
so with something
like this, the training for me
is so much about, as I said,
staying inside myself,
staying with myself,
going moment to moment.
Which I think is
exactly what someone
who was training for
the Olympics would do.
When you've done this
dive four million times,
but this is the one time that
matters, the only way that you
can do that is just by
keeping in contact with you
and what you do, and
not getting swept away
by all this other stuff
that happens outside.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT:
I will say, though,
that it's amazing in
this process how--
that's the way you do it.
How Thomas Hampson does it
is completely different.
ISAIAH BELL: Absolutely.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT:
Karita Mattila they're
all-- opera singers
are real planets.
I mean, I think there
are certain rules
that they have to follow
in order not to spin out
of the universe.
[LAUGHTER]
But in essence,
every single singer,
like every single
voice, is so unique.
And that's one of the
great things about opera,
is that you really--
and it's great and
horrible, thanks--
[LAUGHTER]
--as I look at Peter
with that face.
BOB CORNWALL: Big wide eyes.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: But
yeah, but you just
have this clash of
different methods,
very different methods,
that have to work together.
ISAIAH BELL: Well, I will
say, you sort of jokingly
referred to this
idea of the diva.
And I've actually been
thinking about this.
We have this idea
of divas as being
these people who
just run roughshod
over everyone else's desires.
And just being on
stage with Karita
and with Thomas, who are both
these world-famous celebrated
opera singers, I've
seen the good side
of this idea of the diva.
I mean, the diva means goddess,
like that's what it means.
And it's someone who--
I mean, the idea of
being a planet, someone
that has their own gravitational
pull, is incredible.
Because when you're
out there on your own,
being sort of the figurehead
at the front of this ship that
is driven by so
many people, that
has so many needs
of its own, you
need a sense of
gravity in yourself.
And I think that
the thing that's
great about it is that everyone
does do it differently,
but everyone has to
do it their own way.
And they can't do it
anyone else's way.
And I think that the idea
of the diva, and why people
love opera.
It's because you see someone
who has to do it their own way.
BOB CORNWALL: Yeah, I love that.
I'm curious, Rufus--
you are a performer.
You're on stage.
And in this case, you
are also the composer.
And I'm curious, what
does it feel like?
How is the feeling
different being
a composer versus
performer and vice versa?
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Oh boy.
I mean, being a
performer is my day job.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm much more used to it.
But being the composer is--
I don't know.
I think the one main
difference that I'll say
is that I think with
being a composer,
you are far more sensitive
than you are even aware of.
I mean, you have to have so
much armor and so many weapons
to kind of defend
yourself and your work,
and not get affected by
all the asteroids coming
at your planet.
But then sometimes, a
little notch will break off,
and you'll just be
weeping all of a sudden.
Because you are
feeling incredibly
vulnerable at the same time.
So it's pretty intense.
But we have a question.
BOB CORNWALL: Oh sorry,
I didn't even see.
AUDIENCE: In terms
of your process,
there's always this words
or music, which came first?
And how did you collaborate?
Did you play some
music and then did
you decide what was
going to be sung in that?
And it's been that
way, I guess, over time
with opera composers
and librettists.
So how did it work with you two?
DANIEL MACIVOR: I
delivered a draft to Rufus,
and then that was the basis--
Alexander pointed out recently
that the draft that we have now
is exactly the same number
of pages as the first draft.
It's just that everything
in it is different.
[LAUGHTER]
But we did have a structure.
We adhered to that
structure that I presented
as this idea of the story.
And then sometimes, he
would write to the words,
and sometimes he
would write music,
and I would adapt the words.
And sometimes, we would
just hammer it out together.
We worked a lot.
And when Cori came
in, then we started
working at Opera America, which
is a place on 7th and New York.
And we would sit in the
office and in the boardroom
there and kind of hammer it out.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: It's
kind of a lot like sex.
[LAUGHTER]
In the sense that--
BOB CORNWALL: Go on.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: --you try
a whole bunch of things.
[LAUGHTER]
And you really know
when something works.
[LAUGHTER]
And you kind of stick
with that for a while.
Then that gets a little old, and
you got to try something else.
[LAUGHTER]
And so it's very--
I mean, in a way--
DANIEL MACIVOR: And
then you fall in love.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
BOB CORNWALL: That's amazing.
DANIEL MACIVOR: Isn't that
sort of what happens with sex?
I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
CORI ELLISON: Or you
could be in love first.
DANIEL MACIVOR: Oh yeah.
Oh well--
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: It
was not love first.
DANIEL MACIVOR: We're gay.
[LAUGHTER]
It doesn't go that way.
BOB CORNWALL: Thank
you for your question.
Do we have a question
over here too?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, hi.
So like Bob said earlier, we're
across the street from the Four
Seasons Center, so
opera is very close.
But it's not something
that I go to all the time,
and I'm really looking
forward to enjoying it
next week when I have tickets.
What is your thought
around opera in Canada?
How many people currently
are in that world?
Do you have any ideas--
like, this part of a push
to kind of push into
broader audiences
or anything like that?
And just sort of comment on
opera in Canada in general,
and what that world looks like.
DANIEL MACIVOR:
I don't know much
about opera, period,
or opera in Canada.
But I do know
something about opera,
and I wonder what
this is maybe--
I notice that
people are really--
that we have some
excellent actors.
And I think that that's
something that's newish.
CORI ELLISON: Oh, oh.
DANIEL MACIVOR:
Is that not true?
[LAUGHTER]
CORI ELLISON: That
hurts my heart.
DANIEL MACIVOR: Why?
CORI ELLISON: No, because--
that's a truism
that you hear a lot.
But throughout the
history of opera,
there have been some very,
very great performers.
Not all, but--
DANIEL MACIVOR: I think
we have a number--
I think more that are
not actors in our cast.
And I think it feels
like a more modern thing.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DANIEL MACIVOR: That there's
an attention to that in a way
that there wasn't an
attention to it before.
CORI ELLISON: Well, depends what
you mean by before, and where.
I mean, that's a very big,
sweeping generalization
to make, I feel.
DANIEL MACIVOR: My
feeling, as someone
who doesn't know much
about opera, as I said--
of the operas that I've
seen, my experience
has been that acting
was not really--
that didn't seem to
be that important.
CORI ELLISON: Oh,
I'm sorry that you
happened to see those
particular performances.
[LAUGHTER]
DANIEL MACIVOR:
Yeah, so that was--
and I think there's a lot of it.
I think there is a lot of that.
CORI ELLISON:
Well, I don't know.
DANIEL MACIVOR: I think maybe
you've been really lucky.
CORI ELLISON: Mm, I've
seen a lot of stuff.
DANIEL MACIVOR: But
maybe you've seen
a lot of really good stuff.
CORI ELLISON: Yes,
and bad stuff too.
BOB CORNWALL: I think the
one thing we all agree on
is "Hadrian" in particular
feels really different,
and it feels--
I got to check out a
little bit of it on Tuesday
night when you guys
were rehearsing.
And it feels very
different, and it feels
like it resonates with me.
And it feels like it
resonates with the audience
that I know that's
here at Google.
And I think I'm
really excited to see
what it does in the industry
of Toronto and Canada
and opera in this area.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Well, I
mean, just to sort of try
and mend this gap over
here a little bit--
[LAUGHTER]
BOB CORNWALL: Please.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: I would say,
though, that opera in Canada
actually has a very
distinguished history.
Some of the greatest opera
singers that ever lived
were Canadian.
Back to Albani, right?
Alba--
CORI ELLISON: Emma Albani?
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT:
Emma Albani, who was--
CORI ELLISON: You had Edward
Johnson, who ran the Met.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: And
arguably, from Toronto proper,
one of the greatest
singing actresses
is Teresa Stratus,
who I grew up with,
watching her do "La Traviata"
and stuff like that,
and "Dialogue of
the Carmelites."
And then when you
go to Jon Vickers,
and Maureen Forrester,
and people like that.
I do feel that in Canada,
there has been a kind of--
how can I say--
more of attention paid to the
holistic of being an artist.
And it has translated well
in opera here particularly.
I mean, because you don't have
some somewhere like the Met,
or somewhere like La Scala where
they just kind of like shoot
them out and it's
more of a machine,
here, I think opera is and
has been for many years,
really prized.
Because we're aware
of how special
it is because it's not
taken for granted as much.
BOB CORNWALL: Thank you.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: So that's--
DANIEL MACIVOR: Holistic,
that's the word.
[LAUGHTER]
More holistic.
BOB CORNWALL: That's
what you're looking for.
Last audience question.
AUDIENCE: Yes, I wanted
to go back to the idea
that you brought up,
Isaiah, this idea of history
and going back into history.
We're here in a new city in
a new country with an opera
company that is quite new
in the big scheme of things.
Rufus, you work primarily in
a relatively new art form.
But here with opera,
you're taking an art form
that has centuries
of history that
has changed, of
course, over time,
from a more popular art form to
something that's somewhat more
rarefied air these days.
And you're looking at a story
set in Roman times, which
goes back millennia now.
Can you talk a little
bit about if you
feel any burden of taking
on this mantle of history,
in both the art form and the
story that you're telling?
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Yeah.
I mean, there's one--
it's funny, there hasn't
been much talk about it.
And perhaps my
safe side should be
more on par with the idea of
just not talking about it.
But my Rufus side feels like,
let's just talk about it.
I mean, there is very dark
sides of this opera, which
is that Hadrian was responsible
for the first really
big Jewish massacre.
And it's addressed in the piece.
And he basically
created Palestine.
He kicked the Jews out of Judea.
So this is a situation that
we're very much dealing
with still to this very day.
And in our piece, we address
that, and we work with that.
And so certainly,
embarking on this
with that question
in mind, I was
very worried about how it
would be read, and I still am.
But that being said,
I do feel that--
and I know that Daniel's
totally on board with me here--
is that what we are trying
to put forth is that it's not
so much--
I mean, because within our
opera, we talk about the Jews,
but we also talk
about the Nazarenes,
so the early Christians.
And it's really this whole
concept of monotheism
that is about to
eclipse the pagan world,
and how that, even to this
day, me personally, I feel
was not the best move.
[LAUGHTER]
DANIEL MACIVOR:
On that we agree.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT:
And I'm happy and I'm
happy to stand
behind that theory.
So I don't agree
with the massacre.
I'm not condoning anything.
But I do feel that just on a
personal level, that later on,
when Constantine became
Christian and then turned
the entire empire into
a Christian empire,
for me, that was not a great
day in history, frankly.
And that's an argument
that I'm willing to have.
And I think that this opera kind
of presents that conversation,
which I think is a
conversation that we're
very much engaged in right now.
PETER HINTON: And I do think
it's important to state
that this identification of
Canada as a young country is
really, really dubious,
given the many nations
and cultures upon which
Canada was forged, claimed,
and colonized, civilizations
that have been here
for 10,000 years.
So we have our own empire
drama that we're living now.
And I think it's very resonant
to Canadians in that regard.
BOB CORNWALL: Yeah, thank you.
It's fascinating.
I think it's a really
interesting conversation
and debate.
And you see that riddled
within the play, which I think
is fantastic.
DANIEL MACIVOR: Do we get the
wrestling mats and start--
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BOB CORNWALL: I've
got one more question,
we can land on a bit
of a lighter note.
But I'd love to hear
from each of you.
I'm super curious-- one,
how are you guys feeling
in this moment the day before
the grand opening tomorrow?
And then two, when the
curtains close tomorrow night,
how are you going to celebrate?
[LAUGHTER]
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: I'm Rufus
Wainwright, I am the composer,
and I'm shitting bricks.
[LAUGHTER]
No, I'm good.
I feel really confident.
And I'm kind of ready
to write the next one,
just from sheer fright.
BOB CORNWALL:
Amazing, love that.
And where will you be tomorrow
night when the curtains close?
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: Oh,
when the curtain closes?
BOB CORNWALL: How are
you going to celebrate?
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: I'll be
with my wonderful family,
with my husband, Jorn Weisbrodt,
and my daughter, Viva,
and my aunts and
uncles and cousins.
They've all come
in from Montreal.
BOB CORNWALL: Fabulous.
DANIEL MACIVOR: My
name is Daniel MacIvor,
and I'm the librettist.
[LAUGHTER]
And I am giddy with dread.
Actually, no, I was
giddy with dread.
Actually, after the
dress rehearsal,
I'm feeling like
I'm in the canoe.
I'm just sitting in the canoe.
I've put the paddles down.
I'm going to let
the current take me.
And I trust that
it's a good canoe.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT: We're not too
far from Niagara Falls, right?
[LAUGHTER]
BOB CORNWALL: Oh,
you're far enough.
DANIEL MACIVOR: We're really
far from Niagara Falls.
It's a lake.
It's just a lake, it'll be fine.
BOB CORNWALL: Tomorrow night,
how are you going to celebrate?
DANIEL MACIVOR: I'm going to
eat a bowl of popcorn, fuck it.
[LAUGHTER]
BOB CORNWALL: Amazing.
PETER HINTON: Well, I'm good.
A director's job is
different, because I'm
the guy who carries a lot
of it to the finish line.
And so my job is not over yet.
And we were at the
theater last night
till well past midnight,
and had notes today.
And then tomorrow, I'll go
in and continue to work.
So I do feel good.
And today has been very
interesting for me,
because I got up this
morning exhausted.
And to come to events to
talk about what we're doing
has been healing for me.
It's been really good for my
spirit to be with my creators
and to talk about
what we've been doing.
Because it's so busy there.
Like, I had this moment
last night after the dress,
where when it came down and
the curtain call was finished,
I saw Cori and Rufus embrace.
And I went, oh, that's so nice.
Because it was the
first time I'd seen them
after running something
that they didn't have
10 million notes that they--
[LAUGHTER]
--towards me.
And I went-- that you
could actually go--
we did something.
That was so gratifying.
BOB CORNWALL: Totally.
PETER HINTON: So that's what I
hope to be doing tomorrow night
when it's over.
BOB CORNWALL: Amazing.
PETER HINTON: Is be in a--
[SIGHING]
BOB CORNWALL: Perfect.
AUDIENCE: In an embrace.
PETER HINTON: In an embrace.
BOB CORNWALL: In an
embrace, I love that.
Cori?
CORI ELLISON: Well, I'm
Cori, the dramaturg.
[LAUGHTER]
And the last couple
of weeks have
been sort of a roller coaster.
I mean, there have been
moments where all you can see
is how much there
still remains to do.
And then there are
moments where you just
sit back and feel like, wow,
the effect that this is creating
is tremendous.
And I do, at this
point, especially
after last night's
final dress rehearsal,
I feel tremendous
confidence in the fact
that the audience is going
to be really deeply moved.
Because that's certainly what
we experienced last night.
It was a beautiful
feeling to just feel
the vibe in the place.
And so afterwards, I
expect to feel relieved,
to feel celebratory, maybe
give Rufus another big hug.
[LAUGHTER]
BOB CORNWALL: That
sounds amazing.
And Isaiah?
ISAIAH BELL: Well, every step
of this from when I first
cracked the score to when we had
the first rehearsal, and people
are first hearing it
that aren't just me
and my coaches, to the
first staging rehearsal,
to the first rehearsal
with orchestra,
and then of course last night,
which was the first time
that a wider audience saw it--
every time you think,
OK, this is another step.
And each time, you're aware
that it's a new hurdle
to overcome, and also hopefully,
that it's a new sort of arrow
in your quiver of
telling yourself
that it's going to be fine.
[LAUGHTER]
But the thing
about performing it
is that so much of
your work, of course,
is preparation, and all the
work that we've done together,
and all the discussions we've
had, and all the workshopping.
But the bulk of the work,
really, at this point
is making sure that
your living energy
is ready to be the instrument
in the moment from show to show.
As you know, as
performers, so you
can never feel-- like you ask
about celebration afterwards.
Like of course, if it's a
big success, which we all
expect and hope that it will
be, you're going to be relieved,
and you're going
to have a drink.
My husband's here, and a whole
bunch of my friends are coming.
But you'll also be looking
forward to the next show,
and you're not going to be going
out to the bar till 4:00 AM
and screaming.
Because the whole process
has to start again
for me for every show.
Because really, no matter how
many hurdles you've overcome--
and of course, at this
point in your life,
to get to this you've done a lot
of work for every step that you
go past--
every time you
step on stage, you
have to do it all over again.
And you have to make
it new all over again.
And your aliveness is the
string that you're playing on.
BOB CORNWALL: That's great.
Well, know that we
are all behind you.
And we are sending
positive vibes
supporting you in this moment.
And we all hope that
tomorrow, in that moment when
the curtain closes, that feeling
is exactly what you described
today, and it's
just as delicious
as it can absolutely get.
So thank you very much
for joining us today.
We appreciate your time.
[APPLAUSE]